I may have any issues with insomnia for the last four to six months and I've tried magnesium 3 and 8.
So the magnesium, this magnesium L3 and 8 is the way it's bound, also is called into the brain, the 3 and 8 part.
And magnesium glycinate without success, it seems that I went, I went to a more of a plant-based diet, less meat, the insomnia began.
So THC works, but I really don't want to become dependent any recommendations. So what can't, so another, so there's multiple reasons why a person can't fall asleep or they fall asleep and they wake up and they can't stay asleep.
What else to do with cortisol levels, so which I didn't talk about earlier about insomnia.
This is a big issue with insomnia and more commonly with inability to get back to sleep once the person wakes up and they have to get up to go to the bathroom or something, they can't fall back asleep.
That is more of a cortisol issue and that has to do with stress, dealing with stress in your life, dealing with the anxiety in your heart is really, really important.
That's the best way to handle cortisol, but one little trick can be to eat some protein before you go to bed.
So eat a piece, check it before you go to bed and see if that makes a difference. Do that for a week, eat a half a chicken breast before you go to bed and see if that makes a difference and give that a try.
Also, what can help if stress is your issue is using adaptogens. So we talked a lot about adaptogens.
That adaptogens can be very calming and I know different adaptogenic glands can have GABA in it. So I mentioned GABA before GABA technically essentially adaptogenic herb GABA is during transmitter, it's a call meter or transmitter, but it is commonly in different adaptogenic nutrients blends.